[Music]
what is an Anthem
I felt compelled to explore that
question
everything going on in the country and
the divisions are struggling for
national identity what does it mean to
be American what could delve into that
in a way that could be potentially
healing many reasons we gathered
everyone here is to connect with
different musicians in different towns
and talk about the music from those
areas I jumped at this opportunity
primarily because of this idea of
exploring what an American sound is
what's really fascinating to me I like
to think of the Trail of Tears as a
trail of American music we've been left
out of the American story of Music
what's more American than on a road trip
Chris and dahi went about exploring it
musically and sort of examining America
through the lens of what it sounds like
in those different areas for me I love
things that feel a little bit dangerous
from a sense of just creativity as I
start to think about the anthem and just
the words of the anthem I was like yeah
this song doesn't really tell my story
America boils down to the values that
you have and the way you treat other
people for me it just felt really
incredible to talk to these people about
what their relationship is with music
and how important music is to all of us
it's an attempt to peer perspectives
that hopefully will unify us because
this is home it's where we're from when
you say you don't call it that what what
do you call it ours
that's a joke
[Music]
I'm very intrigued actually to see not
just what the reaction is to it but sort
of what the conversations are going to
be after those reactions I hope people
will listen to it and be like this is a
song that represents our country and
it's an amazing song that's one of the
most exciting things to me is how
conversation and have a conversation in
a way where all sides felt heard and yet
we can still find something to stay
together
[Music]